humans are very basic we've always
needed escapism if I had to choose back
to life being Alternatives a 16 year old
right now from 7 pm to 11 pm at night
playing games versus watching television
which is what her or his parents did 20
years earlier or reading a book for
information that is now at their
fingertip I'll pick gaming because I
think what it's doing is its forming
behavior that is far more relevant to
today's society as we go into a more
machine oriented world the mathematical
structure around gaming psychology the
things they learn the most self-aware
will realize they're getting suckered
into the gamification of it they're
chasing a carrot we chase a carrot
everywhere that's that's what humans do
we're just animals we're very easy to
understand